hi everyone sal khan here just to remind
everyone that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization that means i
don't own khan academy no one owns khan
academy we are a public charity and we
can only do the work we do through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation
as a reminder khan academy is about the
budget of a large high school but we
reach we try to reach all of humanity
last year we had 13 billion learning
minutes on the platform half of that are
students and families all over the world
are coming off often times telling us
that this is the learning resource the
tutor the help that their family could
not otherwise afford the other half is
hundreds of thousands of teachers using
khan academy in the classroom to
personalize learning to make it more
engaging for them to have better
information about where their kids are
so that they can do more focused
interventions with students
there's some calculations around social
return in the for-profit sector if you
get even a 20 or 30
a return on investment that's considered
a very very good return
in the not-for-profit sector if you get
even a 2x or 3x
benefit-to-cost ratio for a a
not-for-profit that's considered very
good
even conservative estimates of khan
academy are 500 to 1 to 1 000 to 1
benefit
because we're at a special time in
history where something like education
which has always been scarce and frankly
always been expensive uh at least
aspects of it very important aspects of
it can now be delivered to
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people
in ways that we could not have imagined
even 20 or 30 years ago
and as i tell everyone as much as khan
academy has done over the last 10 or 12
years and as much as we've done this
past year especially during the pandemic
we're just getting started we really
want to cover all of the core academic
subjects from pre-k through the core of
college we want to meet students where
they are and we want to think about how
do we connect that learning to real
opportunity whether it's getting into
college getting a job or getting credit
in some way and we want to do it one day
for billions of people around the world
so if you're in a position to do so
please think about making a contribution
of any size to khan academy it will go a
long long way